we love you Kenny Ortega you brought us
some of the best musicals the Disney
Channel has to offer
descendants three gave us the peace of
mind we needed to wish the bks the
happily ever after they deserved and we
have to thank you for that
but seriously Kenny don't make us wait
over a decade for descendants for like
you did with High School Musical we wish
we could watch d3 all over again for the
first time and when there's a will
there's a way
so here are some never-before-seen
deleted scenes from descendants three
watch until the end to see what Kenny
Ortega has to say about dissonance for
Disney's taking it all in if you're VK
getting chosen to go to auradon is like
winning the deck pot the pastries have
no flies there's candy for days and
fruits and green leaves grow on trees in
this deleted scene we catch the glimpse
of Evie's castle NCJ doing flips for
carlos squeaky and square meas
entertainment dizzy skips her way onto
the lawn smiling twirling and taking it
all in
she's wearing a funky never-before-seen
dress and is in a state of total awe
dizzy finishes off her moments by saying
how much she loves our Adan she even
calls it her favorite place in the whole
world
Jane's reading in the meet celia trailer
we see celia giving jane a tarot card
reading but for some reason this scene
was cut from the movie hero it's me a
tall handsome stranger luckily there's
an extended version of this deleted
scene in this version we see Jane
hesitantly picking a card out of the
deck
Celia asks Jane to keep the card a
secret and puts her powers to the test
without looking at the card she tells
Jane that she's going to meet a tall and
handsome stranger to which Jane replies
that she already has now that we've seen
the movie were wondering if Jane's
referring to Harry hook or Carlos what
do you guys think the truth will cost
you jane's tarot card reading doesn't
end here instead jane goes on to ask
celia another question she asks Celia if
he'll remember her birthday tomorrow
confirming that she was indeed talking
about Carlos but Celia holds out her
hand instead of answering the question
Jane pays up and the scene cuts right
than in there we would have loved to see
Celia give all of the AKS a very
expensive tarot reading VAT descendants
three was already loaded with crucial
scenes so they had to cut a lot of
is part out of the film pools ball and
this deleted scene we get to see Carlos
MJ playing what seems to be a cross
between foosball and the pole so we're
going to call it pulls ball
we love this deleted scene because it
gives us a chance to see Carlos and Jay
bonding Jay and Carlos used to play a
ton of games together in descendants
they especially loved video games and
we're always messing around with each
other seeing this deleted scene makes us
happy for so many reasons no bikes no
remote where our bikes in descendents 3
we find out that Harry and Gil destroy
the core force bikes during their time
on the Isle we were surprised if they
didn't safely store their bikes
considering the Isle is full of sneaks
and thieves in this deleted scene we see
mal ask Carlos and Jay if they stored
the bikes in the locked garage and the
short answer is no they didn't now
starts making plans to walk to auradon
but Jay mentions that they don't have
the remote to open the barrier the vks
never lost the remote in descendents 3
which makes this deleted scene super
interesting Celia the sneak most of us
were expecting Celia to play a huge hand
in the destruction of our 'adam we
thought she'd be a double agent working
for her father
but in the end Celia was kind helpful
and forgiving the trailers painted her
in a certain light causing us to doubt
her dedication to the core for in this
team we get to see a whole new side of
Celia as it turns out Celia is the one
who stole the remote from Jay but she
was nice enough to give it back to the
vks once they noticed it missing make
sure you get your cuts after finding out
that Celia was the one who stole the
remote the BK's adorably scold her Jays
impressed with silliest thieving skills
after all he used to be the one with the
fast hand reputation
and this deleted scene we caecilia give
dr. facile ear a huge hug she lets him
know she's gone for the night and runs
off
but her dad calls out to her before she
gets too far make sure you get your cook
doctor fast earlier did go on to deliver
this line in the movie but in a very
different scene than this one the story
isn't over at the end of the sentence -
we saw a short clip of uma telling the
audience that the story wasn't over and
in the behind-the-scenes clip we see
Kenny Ortega doing the exact same thing
Kenny sweeps the set before looking up
at the camera and repeating umas famous
line this was the end of the story did
you wonder if Kenny is just messing
around or hinting at his secret plan
there's no way of knowing for sure but
we have to hope that the Disney Channel
will pick up the descendants franchise
once again for future generations
witch deleted scene was your favorite
tell us in the comments must-see deleted
scenes from descendants three and that's
a wrap
thanks for watching the things give this
video a big thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe to our Channel
we'll see you next time
[Music]